I got stopped outside and asked will you
put this pill your mouth get all over
your tongue and then eat a doughnut so
this is crepe crush there are these
little minty tablets that apparently
stop you from tasting sugar for up to an
hour so I'm going to go out and buy some
donuts and have my co-workers test them
out and let's see if this actually works
maybe I'll just ruin Donuts bring them
forever and I'm just a terrible person
did I already know that I can't taste
sugar for an hour smells like a mint
annie is dormant so I want donut so
badly tastes like a minute my tongue
that's the taste of a numbing solution
without numbness I didn't like pop one
of these in right after a meal I'll have
fresh breath and I want one sugar
hopefully
Oh beautiful okay I got this maple
doughnut I didn't know they would be
making doughnuts and I love maple yeah I
don't think the sweetness looks like
soft like semi sweet bread Candice all
right don't taste the chocolate my
Duty's sugar but it's not as like
overwhelming as and usually is yeah
sweetness
Wow that work this is gonna ruin
everything for me now a plus creme
fraiche
[Music]